allora ho appena finito di montare
questo video e mi sono accorto che non
avevo fatto la intro solo che se la
faccio adesso che sono le due di notte
mi cacciano da tutta a milano già solo
per questa cosa che ho appena detto con
questo tono di voce proprio video vi
piaccia è un video con sasha
da ciò che mi piace seguito e quindi
questo è l'altro non era in tronco vesti
cazzi buona visione
essa è un batterio pensa di farne uno
semplice e cos'altro incasinata star o
nei parchi e pensavo fosse più semplice
dei glazer tritacarne qua perché il con
trenta cani in teoria occhio che abbiamo
poco tempo e mi sono buttato dentro il 3
da carne cosa ho fatto
adesso hai creato delle balle è così
però non ho capito che osserva una
realtà aiutami a spingere o spingendo
vinci spingi a2 non solo giu di sotto ha
per niente si e dobbiamo usarla come
scaletta per quello dopo ancora qualche
ora vai vai vai vaganti perche non
abbiamo perso già due minuti ci abbiamo
messo una vita e mezza la testa la testa
sasha
come ti avevo insegnato prima vai vai ha
preso sei riuscito hai messo quindici
minuti noi ce la faremo la coppia salt
enzo scotti non ha messo dieci minuti e
quello standard
ok previi lincoln salito nel martello ok
ok non come sto facendo io buonissimo
bravissimo
no come no no no no veloci non è
possibile ma io lanciato non c'è più di
più alti di così era impossibile e
infatti impossibile
ce l'ho fatta io ci ho fatto come
riprova aeree uguale non lo so ci ho
provato lanciando la fortissima ciò
fatta ma la devi caricare tenendola e no
no no l'ance fi pam non ha certo vai vai
bam bravissimo ok ok per metà da un ca o
diventiamo perché è meglio io ti devo
cliccare il tasto da qualche panno vico
ai qua no così e l'ansia di me va bene
ok io probabilmente devo cliccare questo
mentre tu vai avanti vailatti tutti gli
stati debitori tar devi darti tu però mi
posso buttare dentro è troppo in alto a
tu style inacio buyback barba il io
e faccio io adesso sai ora dovessi
riuscire a treat arti
ok ciao dove la sbarra non ho capito ma
solo con un pezzo di manzo sono
chiaramente se sai dove tutta quella
carne lì non è nelle braccia ma voglio
sapere il nuovo effetto e modo abbiamo
annunciato la testa
no no no basta se la ce la faccia fi
vieni questo vuole è una goduria
il consiglio che poi mi dice miracle
blade ciao bello io ti conosco tu usi il
coltello mozione da qua e là qua porca
di una live da analizzare
nell acido muoviti soldato ho capito un
attimo che poi mi sto perdendo nelle
tazze non sono capaci a fare lavori di
kato esagerato col sapone per i piatti
per te che devo andare
mi sa che non schiacciare il tasto
mentre l'iva il martello macello ok mi
hai fatto mi ha messo tipo non so cosa
comunque mi hai mai avanti pensare di
schiacciare l'altro perché dobbiamo
proseguire sempre questo salta salta
bravissimo sasha
ma quanto ti amo la monaca va giù ma
come mi hai dato che andrai a ok 6th si
rispetta o mio dio mio dio
aspetta aspetta aspetta non ce l'avremmo
fatta
valeva oltre a rispettare di nuovo ciao
bello io titolo nosco toschi li martello
niente ho dimenticato il tasso salt
school bravo ok e morali un bel salto
qui bravo ora devo saltare insieme e
lanciano la testa insieme la casa dove
la testa e dalle sopra
testa insieme e si
però dobbiamo saltare la giovane perché
insieme perché sennò si abbassava
lamenta forme dazio produce com'è
possibile
aveva solo tu puoi tornare dal mio
grande grandissimo avvio alla gamba sola
ah no perché sotto sto pezzo [ __ ]
[ __ ] di ritornare indietro il martello
poi vai arrivo torno indietro poker a
rischio
mi chiamo con no non ci voglio credere
ok ok perfetto o che sparisse torino si
aspetta ok poi vorrà perché il cielo è
perfetto dio ti ringrazio sei vasi che
fanno in tempo a piastra scotta
se anche gli uscito con occhio le
galline li prende le galline lanciati
legali e va bene sono andati a fuoco
mi sa che non ce l'abbiamo fatta in
tempo dipende allora dobbiamo correre
come la madonna prendere la gallina e
lanciarti che legali e ti fanno volare
tantissimo ping del da capito io sono
pure io mi a saltare col e galline
riprendere la devi raccogli una gallina
e la gallina sarà terminato in mano ora
c'è to poli praticamente a prenderla con
sé e poi raccoglie voli perché devi
capire dove andare dopo ha detto ma
devono arrestare
adesso che la vacca ma adesso ha finito
soffitto di quindi è meno male che non
gli farebbe superati che la gallina con
aspetta che arrivò anch'io e poi la
prendiamo
ma quale era sarebbe il times la è
arrivi di prendi occhio che esplode
occhio agli spazi bilanciati se c'è poi
in plancia di social bravo bravissimo
tumori e ce l'ho fatta senza essere
semmai lo fa perché chi vuole che le
galline non lo so non farmi questo io no
però sono arrivato con la pena è come la
pasta dai che ce la facciamo manca poco
per il traguardo finale forza
porca era questa parte la vicinissima
porca vacca antichissimo davvero cosa
facciamo la prego che divertimento
le lame nella nave poi andare anche
piano in realtà riesco a passarci sì sì
ce l'ho fatta vieni vieni
ma se lancio a testa secondo me no no no
certe voglio provare a fare una cosa
stranissima venia se mi riesce ma perché
volevo provare a lasciarmi sul social
point così facciamo insieme questa cosa
guarda arrivi su qualcosa che cosa ti fa
aspetti sfare in altissima propinato
folk e devi cadere sul check point ma
anche a quattro piloti vai ma vado la
ventola solamente una ventola su
sharepoint successo antica del social
point
la ventola ti ti ti ti out dice un po la
caduta bright web e social point su
check point ok ma bona sasha cosa hai
fatto
cosa hai fatto ma tu sei il mio uomo non
lo so
qua è un po casino delle marche tuffa ma
io devo andare miss ad aprirsi la porta
quindi staiano schiacciatasti tu sia
ciliate tiene indietro no non quella
valori schiacciano sia c'è un altro non
un perfetto ri schiaccia quello quello
di no
ok mi spiace ok bravissimo ok
schiacciavano di prima avrei fermo
io non ci credo che è fatta aspettare
che avrà porta devi in 3d mi è mai
passato e di vendere delle lame della
mela me non mi aiutano i passaggi ci
passi ci passi un'idea un'idea ma non ci
credo non ci puoi fare
no ma grossi facevi di miseria scusi ma
rimane presente un [ __ ] come hai
fatto
sono caduto da solo un deficiente per
far sicura che non è una proteina westra
madonna per pochissimo beta già fatta
cioè fatta se corri all'angolo e sei
tiri ce la fai
corri all'angolo e tira ma bravo perché
buona mamma tonio rare l'ansia è che era
dentro di me locale era annidata 15
minuti avevamo 12 e 36 cia che ha messo
neanche troppo poco evitano i ragazzi
per me va bene così ringrazio sasha per
aver partecipato per il solito è stato
devastato fuori le celle che sanno di
pomodoro colori tagliato ok per il
ragazzo che mi sia piaciuto passato
anche la canalis sasha che c'è un altro
video di bene deleghe che lo facciamo
sul suo canale cosa i ragazzi serviva è
piaciuto al momento mi piace anche la
risorge laico miglior notizia ti
sostiene fisica che ci vediamo subito
[Musica]